hey leute heute gibt es mal eine maske
video von mir sehr aktuell den masken
überall ausverkauft
sie werden ganz teuer auf ebay verkauft
und ich zeige euch heute einfach wir in
30 sekunden ihre eigene art maske
herstellen könnt ganz günstig und ganz
schnell dafür benötigt ihr einfach ein
stück stoff das kann zum beispiel auch
ein sauberes geschirr tuch sein oder ihr
nehmt euch einfach ein t shirt und da
schneidet das das ist jetzt hier
freundlicherweise von haben sich zur
verfügung gestellt und ich kann es auch
nicht mehr so schön und jetzt haben ja
die größte das sind hier 25 mal 30
zentimeter zur orientierung und jetzt
schnappt ihr euch einfach dieses stück
stoff und könntest hier umklappen
je nach größe je nach wenn es ein kind
ist macht das kleiner wenn es ein
ausgewachsener ist dann ein bisschen
größer
so und jetzt nimmt ihr euch einfach ein
haargummi und geht einmal beiden seiten
ran und kann das jetzt zweimal oder
einmal so verengen das gleiche von der
anderen seite auch noch mal so und jetzt
braucht ihr eigentlich nur noch ein
stück dass ihr an eurem orbe festigen
könnte nehmen wir uns jetzt wieder zwei
haargummis und gehen hier einmal rein
und verbinden die stücke das geht ganz
einfach so das gleiche von der anderen
seite auch noch mal und dann haben wir
es
so das war's schon fertig ist die maske
aufsetzen und wieder frisches mit dem
strahl liste so unfertig sitzt wackelt
und hat luft perfekt sonderlasten daumen
bahn und kostenloses abo und dann sind
wir uns beim nächsten mal mit einem
leckeren rezepte oder ein blog oder
körpers toya